this is a character that loves so much
in the future and the what if in fear
hmm um that there's no room for anything
else I mean that's what I find
interesting about the movie or the
character I'm sorry I have a cold so I'm
talking like a little extra like me
because I think that people will um
either have empathy for her sympathy for
her or just total disdain and what you
come away with has everything to do with
the prism of your own experience through
which you are seeing this movie and I
love that that's what I like about art
you know so that what she was afraid of
became the truth of her existence right
so she you know they say if you live in
the past that's depression and if you
live in the future that's anxiety and
that's why we're supposed to live in the
present moment as much as we can so that
we're both anxious and depressed like
ideally you're just in the moment you
know but that's that's something that we
all have to only just practice nobody's
really great at it but she lives
completely in the future and of what if
what if what if the horror stories we
tell ourselves and so there isn't room
for anything else like being the mother
she wants to be or hope and it becomes a
self-fulfilled prophecy and with that
just glimmer of when everything is lost
the one thing she can't control is the
destruction she has over her own life
and there's just that one glimmer of
just what she can do without thinking or
without terrifying you know without
talking herself out of it with fear is
just the bags and the drying in the
sandwich and the meditative kind of
ritual things that that a mother does so
it just seemed like a good something
that would bring more to it you know
you're you're coming out of this movie
what followed a slightly unusual path
and that you got to copy the book
read the book were interested in what it
would be as a movie and committed to
that idea before there was a screenplay
before there was a director I had
nothing to lose hey you know what I will
you will you attach yourself to this
movie yeah sure I mean most movies don't
get made so it it never occurred to me
this movie would get made and I just
said III didn't even have to have a
think about it I was like yeah sure sure
sure sure sure yeah well then what
happens when they call you and they say
it is getting made a couple years later
I got an email a bulk email everyone
involves saying we have the money we're
making this this is happening and I
respond i replied all in wrote yay I
remember I was in my bathroom i press
send and then I just kind of descended
into this ball on the bathroom bath mat
of my bathroom and I thought I can't do
this I can't do this you know and I am
and in my full body panic attack i
realized that i could do it because i
was doing it that's Laney Laney is
living in the future of fear of what if
of I can't and and so I kind of proved
to myself in a ball on the floor that I
can do this one of the things that you
just mentioned is that people are going
to have different experiences watching
the movie they're going to think
differently about Laney about what they
think of her and what they think of her
behavior I'm curious from reading the
book to committing to making a movie to
filming the movie to watching the movie
did your relationship with laney evolve
as well or was it always fixed in terms
of how you saw her I think you to a
degree you have to always be on your
characters side as an actor because I've
heard a lot of actors say that on inside
the actor what I wanted I want Anna into
a degree I do feel that way and I I I
wanted to play her as real and concise
and as objectively as possible because I
thought it was in
that people see this movie and see this
person the way we see all people just in
the context of her own experience of
what we know and so yeah I wanted to I
had stuff to drawn from my own life I've
I've navigated depression in my own life
I haven't struggled with addiction but
i'm a comedian so I'm surrounded by it
and by comedians who are fighting to be
so I comedians by every lot of people in
the audience by the people who come up
to you after and um it's just kind of
everywhere you know in that world that
nighttime world and what is that how
does it help you as an actor being
around people who are struggling with
sobriety or being around people who are
really trying to stay focused and stay
part of the world well one thing that I
noticed about drunk people is they they
their job is to act not drunk so that's
always interesting because acting is is
most interesting when it's you feel
something and you're covering that
feeling and laney totally exists in that
and so it's interesting to see it's
interesting to take in it can also be
very unpleasant for me I'm not I'm a
teetotaler and sometimes donor but I a
human um behavior is interesting to me
I'm lucky I got an incredible therapist
and I've learned so much about myself
and people and watching people and it's
helped me in my what I do with what I do
completely part of the challenge in the
adapting of this book is the the book is
very largely an inner monologue there's
not a lot of dialogue there's certainly
events and those events are preserved in
the book but I think one of the
challenges of adapting this book and I
think your screen writers did it very
well is making sure that there wasn't
judgment brought
beurer both in how the audience would
see Lainey and I think more specifically
how her husband would treat her when
you're talking to your collaborators and
talking to Josh about the marriage about
the relationship at the center of this
film what were the kinds of things that
you wanted to talk about that you were
really focused on preserving from the
book I don't know we had talked about a
lot of things that we wanted to know
about ourselves that isn't you know a
part of the movie like that maybe we had
worked together that we had that I had
worked with him an insurance that we had
built something together and that when I
became a mother housewife I started
judging him and that was really helpful
for him and for me you know and and you
know a lot of looking down at someone is
is comes from how you feel about
yourself of course so it was it was
stuff that was very helpful just in how
you played stuff like when I was at
dinner with his clients or you know that
kind of demeaning behavior that it comes
from feeling shitty about yourself and
who you are and you know it's the bully
behavior you know or or when people go
like you think you're better than me um
that's cuz you know you know you think
I'm better than you're really good
that's how you feel um that's not a
quote from my actual life but you might
have